Narrator:
THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
THIS PRODUCT IS GONNA CHANGE
THE WAY THE WORLD POTTY TRAINS.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
[ LAUGHS ]
IT'S BROOKIE TIME!
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
TWO GUYS WITH HAIRCUTS LIKE THIS
CAN GO A LONG WAY, BUDDY.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
IT SHOULD BE PAINFUL
IF IT'S A GREAT DEAL.
DUDE, HE'S TRYING
TO WIPE YOU OUT.
MARK, WHEN YOU MAKE
COMMENTS LIKE THAT --
YOU'RE NOT EVEN
IN THE DEAL.
IT'S TRUE. IT'S TRUE.
IT'S OUR MONEY.
WE CAN DO WHAT WE WANT.
Narrator:
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS MUST GET
THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
THEY'RE JUST BEING GREEDY.
WHICH ONE OF YOU
IS FULL TIME?
NONE OF US.
[ SIGHS ]
YOU'RE A HOBBY,
YOU'RE NOT A BUSINESS.
IT'S ENDLESS WHAT WE COULD DO
ON THE HEAT-AND-SERVE END.
YOU HAVE NO PROOF OF CONCEPT
WHATSOEVER.
I GREW UP AS
A LITTLE MARK CUBAN.
I'M NOT BUYING IT. YOU'RE A BAKE
SALE, YOU'RE NOT A BUSINESS.
BARBARA,
YOU MAKING AN OFFER?
YEAH, I'LL MAKE AN OFFER,
BUT I WANT
A LOT MORE
OF YOUR BUSINESS.
FUHGEDDABOUDIT.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT
FROM WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIERE
$2-BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
♪♪
MY NAME IS THOMAS CUCCO,
I'M FROM BROOKLYN, NEW YORK,
AND I OWN TABLE 87 PIZZA.
WHO WANTS A FRESH SLICE
OF COAL-OVEN PIZZA?
I OFFER MY CUSTOMERS
THE FRESHEST, HIGHEST-QUALITY
PIZZA ON THE MARKET.
WE USE ONLY
THE BEST INGREDIENTS --
FRESH MOZZARELLA, FRESH BASIL,
TOMATOES IMPORTED FROM ITALY,
AND, OF COURSE,
OUR UNIQUE, THIN-CRUST DOUGH
THAT CHARS IN OUR
900-DEGREE COAL-FIRED OVEN.
TAKE ONE BITE, AND YOU'LL KNOW
THERE'S NO SUBSTITUTION.
FUHGEDDABOUDIT.
PACO, WE NEED
ANOTHER PIE.
BORN AND RAISED IN BROOKLYN,
NEW YORK. I LOVE PIZZA.
I OPENED UP MY FIRST SHOP
HERE ON ATLANTIC AVENUE IN 2012.
WE GOT SO POPULAR, I HAD TO
OPEN UP A SECOND LOCATION,
AND THAT'S WHEN IT HIT ME.
IF MY CUSTOMERS
LOVE MY PIZZA THAT MUCH,
I HAD TO FIGURE A WAY TO GET
MY PIZZA TO EVERYONE EVERYWHERE.
SAUCE IS READY?
BEAUTIFUL.
YEAH.
I NEED AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS
TO PURCHASE MORE EQUIPMENT
AND TO STREAMLINE MY OPERATION.
I HAVE BIG PLANS
FOR THIS BUSINESS,
AND I HOPE ONE DAY
TO PASS THIS ON TO MY CHILDREN,
WHERE THEY CAN CARRY ON THIS
LEGACY FOR GENERATIONS TO COME.
I THINK THE SHARKS ARE GONNA
LOVE OUR PIZZA.
ANY WAY YOU SLICE IT, MAKING
THIS DEAL IS A NO-BRAINER.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS THOMAS CUCCO,
AND I'M FROM BROOKLYN, NEW YORK.
MY COMPANY IS TABLE 87
FROZEN COAL OVEN PIZZA,
HOME OF THE COAL-OVEN SLICE.
I AM HERE SEEKING $200,000
FOR 10% OF EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
HEY, SHARKS, ARE YOU FAMILIAR
WITH THE FROZEN-PIZZA GAME?
YES.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
YOU WERE ABLE TO BUY
FROZEN, COAL-OVEN PIZZA
BY THE SLICE OR PIE?
I'M GONNA TELL YOU WHEN --
NEVER, UNTIL NOW.
[ CORCORAN LAUGHS ]
HEY, MARCO, LET'S SHOW THEM
THE WAY THIS UNIQUE EAST COAST
DOUGH WORKS.
♪♪
THAT'S A
BROOKLYN-STYLE TOSS.
Herjavec: OH.
[ LAUGHS ]
GREAT JOB.
WOW.
I PRIDE MYSELF ON USING
ONLY THE FINEST OF INGREDIENTS,
SUCH AS FRESH MOZZARELLA,
FONTINA CHEESE,
ALTA CUCINA TOMATOES,
REGGIANO PARMESAN,
DRIZZLED WITH 100% OLIVE OIL,
TOPPED OFF WITH FRESH BASIL.
MY PIES ARE INCREDIBLE.
MY PIZZA'S COOKED IN
A 900-DEGREE, COAL-FIRED OVEN,
WHERE MY PIZZA FLASH-COOKS
IN UNDER TWO MINUTES.
MY PIZZA GOES
FROM MY COAL OVEN TO YOUR TABLE
IN A MATTER OF MINUTES.
FUHGEDDABOUDIT.
I CAN SEE YOUR MOUTHS
ARE WATERING. HOW ABOUT A TASTE?
MARCO, LET'S FEED
THESE SHARKS.
FUHGEDDABOUDIT.
MARK, I GOT YOU A BEAUTIFUL,
GLUTEN-FREE, CERTIFIED PIE.
THAT'S WHAT'S UP
RIGHT THERE. YES, SIR.
I WANT YOU TO ENJOY IT.
YOU'RE MY NEW HERO.
-THAT'S MINE, THOMAS?
-THANK YOU.
-YOU GOT IT, BARBARA.
-YUMMY!
-OH, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT IS A --
THAT IS A NEW YORK-STYLE...
-MMM!
-THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
...BROOKLYN, COAL-OVEN SLICE.
-FRESH, HUH?
-OH, MY GOD!
THAT'S GOOD PIE.
THIS IS EXCELLENT.
THAT COMES OFF
OUR 20-INCH PIE,
AND THAT'S THE SLICE
WE PACKAGE
AND SELL TO THE --
TO THE SUPERMARKETS.
YOU'RE BASICALLY FLASH-FREEZING
PIZZA YOU MAKE, RIGHT?
YES.
AND SO THEN YOU ARE
SELLING IT TO DISTRIBUTORS
TO PUT IT IN
RETAIL FREEZERS, RIGHT?
CORRECT.
THAT'S A TOUGH BUSINESS.
PIZZA IS A COMMODITY.
YES, IT IS.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF PLAYERS,
LARGE AND SMALL,
IN THE FROZEN-PIZZA
BUSINESS.
TELL ME WHY YOU ARE GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT THAN THEY ARE.
WELL, YOU KNOW,
I'VE ALWAYS FELT THAT YOU WERE
NEVER REALLY ABLE TO GET
A REALLY QUALITY PIE FROZEN.
I DECIDED WHEN I OPENED
MY COAL OVEN SHOPS
THAT I WAS GONNA CHANGE
ALL THAT.
I THEN STARTED TO DEVELOP
PACKAGING WHERE I WAS ABLE
TO FLASH-FREEZE MY PIZZA AND
GET IT INTO THE SUPERMARKETS.
ARE YOU IN
THE SUPERMARKETS?
WE ARE IN 250 SUPERMARKETS,
SOME OF THEM BEING
WHOLE FOODS MARKET...
WOW.
...FAIRWAY MARKET.
Herjavec:
AND WHAT DO YOU SELL THEM FOR?
THE PIE SELLS TO THE MARKET
FOR $6.50.
THE SUGGESTED RETAIL
IS $9.99 ON THE PIE.
THE SLICE SELLS
TO THE MARKET AT $3.
SUGGESTED RETAIL IS $4.99.
AND HOW IS IT SELLING?
WHAT ARE THE SELLS LIKE?
WE STARTED THE BUSINESS
NINE MONTHS AGO
ON THE FROZEN END OF IT.
MY TOTAL SALES
HAS BEEN $260,000.
AND WHERE DO YOU MAKE
THE PIES?
WE ARE CURRENTLY
MAKING THE PIES
IN OUR BRICK-AND-MORTARS
RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
WHY IS THAT?
YOU WORK THROUGH THE NIGHT?
YOU WANT TO
SCALE THIS BUSINESS,
YOU NEED A COMMERCIAL KITCHEN
WITH THE SAME QUALITY.
YEAH, AND THAT'S
WHAT I'M HERE FOR.
THE $200,000 WOULD BE USED
FOR OVENS.
THOMAS, ARE YOU OFFERING US
A PIECE OF YOUR WHOLE BUSINESS,
OR IS IT SIMPLY
THIS OPERATION?
I'M OFFERING
10% OF MY FROZEN COMPANY.
ONLY -- BUT --
NOT THE RESTAURANTS?
NOT THE BRICK-AND-MORTARS.
BUT YOUR RESTAURANT BUSINESS
IS PICKING UP
A LOT OF THE EXPENSE.
YOU'RE USING THOSE OVENS.
YOU'RE USING
THE SIMILAR PERSONNEL,
IF NOT THE SAME PEOPLE.
HOW DO WE KNOW
WHAT PART OF THE PIE IS OURS
AND HOW MUCH IS YOURS?
IN ORDER -- IN ORDER TO REALLY
START SCALING THIS COMPANY,
WE NEED TO GET THIS THING
UNDER ONE ROOF.
TOTALLY SEPARATE?
TOTALLY SEPARATE.
WE NEED TO PUT IT UNDER --
IT'S GOT TO BE ITS OWN ENTITY
AT THIS POINT.
THOMAS, DO YOU KNOW WHY
THE BIG BRANDS LIKE DOMINO'S
DON'T GO INTO
THE FROZEN-PIZZA SECTION?
'CAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
NO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO. NO, THEY KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THEY KNOW
THEY'RE -- THEY'RE THE LARGEST
PIZZA PLAYER ON EARTH.
SO, THE COST OF MAINTAINING,
ON A SCALED BASIS,
SOME FOOTAGE
INSIDE A FREEZER
IN A BIG-BOX RETAILER
IS REALLY HIGH.
EXPENSIVE.
I HAVEN'T HAD A PROBLEM YET.
I NEVER PAID ONE SLOTTING FEE.
I'VE NEVER BEEN ASKED FOR --
'CAUSE YOU'RE SMALL!
YOU'RE LOCAL,
YOU'RE SMALL, AND --
YOU'RE SMALL.
AND WE ARE SMALL.
BUT LISTEN, FOR A NEW YORKER
TO BUY PIZZA PACKAGED FROZEN,
THE WAY THEY'RE BUYING
OUR PRODUCT,
IT SAYS A LOT
FOR OUR PRODUCT.
BUT LET'S -- YO, YO, YO, YO,
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS, RIGHT?
WHAT DOES IT TAKE --
I TAKE THIS BACK.
CAN I POP IT
IN A MICROWAVE?
IT'S A
FULLY-COOKED PRODUCT.
YOU COULD TAKE THIS OUT
AND LEAVE IT ON YOUR DESK,
AND IN 20 MINUTES, IT'LL BE
WARM ENOUGH TO START EATING IT.
RIGHT.
IT'S FULLY COOKED.
YOU'RE NOT COOKING IT.
RIGHT,
YOU'RE JUST HEATING IT.
YOU'RE JUST HEATING IT
RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT.
IT'S A HEAT-AND-SERVE ITEM.
SEE, TO ME,
THAT'S THE UPSIDE, RIGHT?
WE'RE GOING INTO
AN ON-DEMAND ECONOMY, RIGHT?
OF COURSE.
WHERE PEOPLE
WANT THINGS WHEN THEY WANT,
HOW THEY WANT...
RIGHT AWAY.
...WITH THE MOST
CONVENIENCE, RIGHT?
JUST TAKE THESE
AND JUST CRANK 'EM OUT.
THROW THEM IN
THE MICROWAVE -- $4.99.
I SEE A BUSINESS THERE.
DO YOU SELL ANYTHING
ONLINE AND SHIP?
WE HAVE AN ONLINE --
WE HAVE OUR ONLINE LAUNCHING
IN ABOUT THREE WEEKS
FROM NOW.
WE ARE IN GOOD EGGS. WE ARE
LAUNCHING WITH FRESH DIRECT.
AMAZON FRESH HAS
A BIG INTEREST IN US.
THAT'S THE GOLD MINE.
OKAY, SO, LOOK AT IT THIS WAY.
FORGET THE STORES!
BE THE GODFATHER OF THIS
ON-DEMAND DELIVERY IN PIZZA.
RIGHT.
TRYING TO GET INTO
ALL THESE STORES
IN THE FROZEN-FOOD SECTION
IS A BEAR.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE --
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING.
Herjavec: THOMAS, LOOK --
I EAT A LOT OF PIZZA.
IT'S ACTUALLY
A VERY HEALTHY FOOD.
UM...BRUTAL,
BRUTALLY COMPETITIVE MARKET.
SOMETIMES IT'S BETTER TO BE
A BIG FISH IN A LITTLE POND.
I THINK FOR YOU
TO TAKE AN INVESTMENT
AND TRY TO GO AFTER
THAT MAJOR...
SPACE IS GONNA BE
VERY DIFFICULT.
ROBERT, WE WANT TO EXPAND.
THE REASON WE NEED
THESE FOUR OVENS NOW
IS TO SET UP POSSIBLY 5,000,
10,000 BARS IN NEW YORK CITY.
I MEAN, IT'S ENDLESS
WHAT WE COULD DO
ON THE HEAT-AND-SERVE END.
I'M NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
THE SUPERMARKETS.
SUPERMARKETS ARE A GREAT PLACE
TO BE IN.
I UNDERSTAND
IT'S VERY COMPETITIVE.
BUT THE BARS, THE ARENAS --
THEY'RE IN THERE HAVING A BEER.
THEY WANT IT RIGHT NOW.
I JUST SEE THAT
AS TOO RISKY.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
THOMAS, I GOT TO TELL YOU --
IT'S SO GOOD,
BUT THERE'S NO WAY
THE IDEA'S WORTH $2 MILLION.
I'M GONNA WAIT.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS HERE.
OH, NOW YOU'RE STEALING
ALL MY LINES.
I'M SORRY.
[ CHUCKLES ]
HE CERTAINLY IS.
-THAT IS MARK'S LINE.
-YEAH.
-LET ME FILL IN THE BLANKS HERE.
WELL, TOO BAD.
IT'S MY LINE NOW.
[ LAUGHS ]
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I LOVE
ABOUT THIS BUSINESS.
YOU'RE THE REAL DEAL,
THE REAL PERSONALITY.
EVERYBODY'S
RESPONDING TO YOU.
WHO WOULD LOVE TO HANG OUT
IN YOUR KITCHEN?
ALL OF US, RIGHT?
THERE YOU GO.
YEAH.
I HAPPEN TO THINK
THAT YOU'RE GOING IN
A COUPLE OF DIRECTIONS AT ONCE,
AND SOME OF THEM
AREN'T SO WISE.
UH-HUH.
I DON'T EVEN THINK
YOU'RE GONNA DO SO WELL
SELLING ONLINE
BECAUSE THERE'S --
YOU DON'T THINK SO?
YEAH. LET'S SAY
THAT WE DID A DEAL TOGETHER.
YEAH.
YOU HAVE TO COMMIT
THAT YOU'RE ONLY GONNA SELL
SINGLE SLICES.
THAT'S YOUR SWEET SPOT HERE.
THAT IS. THAT IS. THAT IS
A DIAMOND IN THE ROUGH WE HAVE,
I THINK,
IS THE SINGLE SLICE.
BUT HERE'S STILL
WHAT BOTHERS ME.
HOW DO I KNOW WHAT'S MINE
AND WHAT'S YOURS?
I MEAN, YOU -- YOU --
YOU'RE THE KIND OF GUY,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE AN IDEA
IN A MINUTE --
"HEY, NOT ONLY THAT,
I'M GONNA DO THIS,
AND NOT ONLY THAT."
NOW YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT BARS.
IS THAT MY BUSINESS?
IS THAT YOUR BUSINESS?
IS THAT
YOUR PIZZA BUSINESS?
NO, THAT -- THAT WOULD BE
A PART OF THE FROZEN BUSINESS.
I THINK ANYTHING WE DO
UNDER THE FROZEN ROOF
WOULD BE A PART OF --
PART OF THE BUSINESS.
IT'S ALL FROZEN?
EXACTLY.
MY BRICK-AND-MORTARS
ARE THERE
STRICTLY TO BUILD UP
THIS PRODUCT, BUILD THE BRAND.
YEAH.
PEOPLE COME IN, THEY GET A SLICE
OFF THE COUNTER.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN BUY US
IN THE SUPERMARKET.
BARBARA,
ARE YOU MAKING AN OFFER?
YEAH,
I'LL MAKE AN OFFER,
BUT I WANT A LOT MORE
OF YOUR BUSINESS.
OH!
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT.
BARBARA LIKES
THOMAS' FROZEN-PIZZA COMPANY,
TABLE 87 PIZZA,
BUT SHE WANTS A BIGGER SLICE
THAN THE 10%
HE CAME IN OFFERING.
I'LL MAKE AN OFFER, BUT I WANT
A LOT MORE OF YOUR BUSINESS.
AS ADORABLE AS YOU ARE,
I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000 FOR 30%.
OH!
OUCH.
-SHE'S NOT SO ADORABLE NOW.
-HE'S GOT A BABY BUSINESS.
-YEAH, OUCH.
WOW, SHE TOOK A WHOLE SLICE
OUT OF YOUR PIE.
[ Laughing ]
A WHOLE SLICE.
I GOT TO TELL YOU,
I THOUGHT --
BUT I CAN MAKE YOUR PIE
A LOT BIGGER --
A LOT BIGGER, FASTER.
I'LL MAKE IT INTERESTING
FOR YOU.
JUST 'CAUSE I LIKE
TO MESS WITH BARBARA
A LITTLE BIT
AND GIVE YOU
OTHER OPTIONS.
UM...I DON'T THINK
IT IS POSSIBLE
TO SEPARATE THE BUSINESSES
OR YOU FROM IT...
I DON'T EITHER.
...BECAUSE YOU'RE THE REAL DEAL,
AND I FEEL YOUR ENERGY,
AND ONE OF THE REASONS
I'M LOVING THE PIE IS THE STORY,
ALL OF THAT AROUND IT.
YOU'RE THE GUY, OKAY?
YOU NEED CAPITAL.
SO, I HAVE A DEAL
THAT'S VERY SIMILAR TO THIS
CALLED
WICKED GOOD CUPCAKES,
WHERE I OWN
NO EQUITY, ZERO.
RIGHT.
NOTHING.
IT'S A FAMILY BUSINESS,
AND IT'S GROWING LIKE HELL.
THEY PAID ME BACK
THROUGH A ROYALTY, ALL RIGHT?
IF YOU WANT TO
GO INTO A DEAL LIKE THAT,
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $200,000,
AND ONLY ON THE FROZEN,
YOU PAY ME BACK A LITTLE BIT
EVERY SLICE.
I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000.
WHAT CAN YOU AFFORD
TO PAY ME PER SLICE?
WELL, IF I DID A ROYALTY,
IF I DECIDED TO DO A ROYALTY,
I COULD PROBABLY PAY 25 CENTS
ON A SLICE.
OKAY, SO LET'S SAY
IT'S 25 CENTS.
AFTER I GET BACK --
BACK $600,000, WE'RE DONE.
[ EXHALES SHARPLY ]
WOW.
I HELPED YOU BUILD IT.
WE'RE PARTNERS.
IF YOU STILL LOVE ME AFTER THAT,
YOU KEEP ME ON BOARD.
IT'S YOUR DECISION.
THAT'S CALLED A LOAN SHARK.
I WOULD DO THE TRADE THIS --
I COULD PROBABLY GET THAT MONEY
ON 18th AVENUE.
[ LAUGHS ]
YEAH, BUT YOU WOULDN'T --
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE ME.
IT SAVES SOME MONEY.
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE ME,
AND I THINK TWO GUYS
WITH HAIRCUTS LIKE THIS
CAN GO A LONG WAY, BUDDY.
I THINK WE COULD.
I'M GONNA THINK ABOUT IT.
-ALL RIGHT.
-I THINK YOU SHOULD.
-I'M GONNA THINK ABOUT IT.
I WOULD NOT GIVE UP
30% OF YOUR BUSINESS
TO ANY OF THESE SHARKS.
THAT'S TOO GREEDY.
WELL, MAYBE LORI HAS
AN OFFER, THOMAS.
HI, LORI.
I HAVE AN OFFER, THOMAS,
BECAUSE I ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER
YOU CAN'T REFUSE.
MY OFFER'S GOING TO BE --
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $250,000...
Herjavec: WHOA.
...FOR 20%...
BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA NEED
A LITTLE BIT MORE MONEY
IN THE BEGINNING TO RAMP UP.
I ALSO HAVE
A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH ALL THE NATURAL-FOOD CHAINS
OUT THERE.
I LIKE THE SLICE, BUT
I ALSO LIKE SELLING THE PIE.
I THINK THERE'S A MARKET
FOR BOTH.
BUT I ALSO LIKE YOUR IDEA
OF ALSO GETTING IT OUT THERE
INTO BARS
AND OTHER PLACES.
IN THE VENUES.
I BELIEVE WHY NOT?
IF YOU HAVE THE MANPOWER
AND THE BRAINPOWER
AND YOU PLAN IT OUT
CORRECTLY...
THAT'S RIGHT.
...YOU CAN HIT
ALL PLACES.
EXACTLY.
WOW, THOMAS.
SO, I REALLY
WANT IN.
I LIKE THAT. I LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU, LORI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Herjavec:
WOW, SHE GAVE YOU MORE THAN
YOU WERE LOOKING FOR.
SHE DID.
MARK, WHAT ARE YOU?
ARE YOU IN?
MARK, WE ARE LAUNCHING OUR
GLUTEN-FREE PRODUCT THIS FALL,
ALONG WITH
TWO OTHER PRODUCTS.
IT'S GONNA BE
THE MUSHROOM WHITE TRUFFLE OIL
AND THE
PROSCIUTTO-LACED PIE.
WOW.
THOSE ARE OUR TWO TOP SELLERS
IN THE STORE.
THIS YEAR, WE'RE GONNA BRING
$3 MILLION INTO TWO STORES.
NOT BAD.
YOU KNOW, I LOVE THE IDEA,
EXCEPT FOR THE STORES.
OKAY.
I HATE THE IDEAS
OF THE STORES.
I THINK YOUR GOLD MINE
IS THROUGH ON-DEMAND.
CREATING
AN INFRASTRUCTURE
TO GO AND SELL AT RETAIL
IS DIFFICULT.
THOMAS, YOU'VE DONE PRETTY WELL
ON YOUR OWN.
SCALING THAT
IS DIFFICULT.
THE WHOLE
FRESH DIRECT SIDE,
I THINK THAT'S WHERE
YOU SHOULD STICK.
I'LL BE A CUSTOMER,
BUT I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, MARK.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec: ALL RIGHT, THOMAS,
THERE IS -- THERE IS NO --
THOMAS, COME BACK.
COME BACK TO ME FOR A MINUTE.
THERE IS NO DOUGH
COMING FROM MARK.
I WANT YOU, THOMAS.
SHE WANTS YOU.
TAKE IT.
ONE QUESTION EACH.
AND MY OFFER IS
$250,000...
MM-HMM.
...20%, BUT YOU NEED
TO TELL ME NOW.
NO.
LORI, WOULD YOU
CONSIDER 18%?
NO.
I'D CONSIDER 19%.
18.5%.
NO, THOMAS, LISTEN TO ME.
I HAVE A BETTER DEAL HERE.
DONE!
SUGAR! I SHOULD'VE
MOVED FASTER.
YEAH.
OH, MY GOD.
I'M SO EXCITED!
I HATE LOSING TO LORI!
OH!
YOU'RE ALWAYS WELCOME
TO THE STORE.
THOMAS, THIS IS --
I'M NOT JOKING YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE GOT IT.
THANK YOU, LORI.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE THE BEST.
SHARKS, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Cuban:
CONGRATS, THOMAS.
MARK, WE'LL SEE YOU
IN BROOKLYN.
I'LL NEVER SEE YOU AGAIN,
THOMAS. I'M A SCORNED WOMAN.
WE DID IT, MARCO!
WE GOT IT A SHARK.
WE DID IT.
WE GOT 'EM.
Cucco:
I AM SO HAPPY RIGHT NOW.
I WALKED OUT OF "SHARK TANK"
WITH A DEAL.
NERVOUS WALKING IN
AND A JOYFUL WALKING OUT.
IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
Narrator: IN SEASON SIX,
ALICE BROOKS AND BETTINA CHEN
MADE A DEAL FOR ROOMINATE,
WHICH TEACHES BUILDING
AND ENGINEERING SKILLS
TO BOYS AND GIRLS.
I'M GONNA OFFER YOU $500,000
FOR 5%.
YES, YOU HAVE A DEAL.
LET'S SEE WHAT THEY'RE
UP TO NOW.
Brooks: SINCE WE MADE OUR DEAL
ON "SHARK TANK,"
MARK'S PLAYED A HUGE ROLE
IN HELPING US EXPAND
OUR RETAIL PRESENCE.
WE CLOSED A MAJOR DEAL
WITH WALMART.
ROOMINATE IS NOW
BEING SOLD
IN 800 STORES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND ONLINE.
ARE YOU GUYS
ALL READY TO PLAY?
All: YEAH!
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
BECAUSE TODAY,
WE HAVE AN IN-STORE DEMO,
AND IT'S GONNA
GIVE KIDS A CHANCE
TO TRY ROOMINATE HANDS-ON.
WE'RE MAKING A HOUSE.
IT'S MORE OF A MANSION BECAUSE
IT'S PRETTY BIG.
YEAH.
Chen:
WITH OUR EXPANSION INTO RETAIL,
OUR SALES
HAVE REALLY SURGED.
BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
OUR SALES WERE
$1.7 MILLION
IN A YEAR AND A HALF.
IT'S BEEN A YEAR SINCE
WE APPEARED ON "SHARK TANK,"
AND WE'VE DONE
OVER $4.5 MILLION IN SALES.
Brooks: AND THAT'S BEFORE
THE WALMART DEAL.
THIS DEAL ALONE COULD
INCREASE OUR SALES BY MILLIONS.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S TRY OUT
LIGHT NUMBER ONE.
ALL RIGHT.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT A YEAR AGO,
IT WAS JUST
THE TWO OF US.
NOW WE HAVE
EIGHT EMPLOYEES,
AND WE'VE MOVED INTO OUR
VERY OWN ROOMINATE HEADQUARTERS.
LET'S TURN IT ON NOW.
AH, YOU GUYS,
IT'S WORKING!
AND WE'VE INTRODUCED
AN EXCITING, NEW TECHNOLOGY
CALLED "R" POWER,
WHICH ALLOWS KIDS
TO PROGRAM AND CONTROL
THEIR CREATIONS
FROM THE BRAND-NEW
ROOMINATE APP.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
OUR MISSION
TO EMPOWER GIRLS
TO BECOME BUILDERS
AND MAYBE ONE DAY,
ENGINEERS.
BECAUSE OF MARK AND
"SHARK TANK," WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO SPREAD OUR MESSAGE
AND GET OUR TOYS TO GIRLS
WHO WILL ONE DAY BUILD
OUR FUTURE.
All: ROOMINATE!
♪♪
Narrator: NEXT UP IS
A PRODUCT DESIGNED TO SIMPLIFY
THE TEACHING OF SOMETHING
WE ALL HAVE TO LEARN.
HELLO, SHARKS,
MY NAME IS BRIAN KLEINSCHMIDT,
AND I'M A DAD-TREPRENEUR
FROM TAMPA, FLORIDA.
I'M HERE TO SECURE $50,000
FOR 15% OF MY DREAM.
MY COMPANY IS EZ-PEE-Z,
AND I'M CONFIDENT MY PRODUCT
IS GONNA FLIP YOUR LID.
ONE OF MY FIRST EXPERIENCES
AS A STEPDAD
WAS THE INEVITABLE
POTTY-TRAINING PHASE.
PERFECT TIMING, RIGHT?
I WAS SHOCKED
AND DISGUSTED TO SEE
THAT THE SAME TYPE
OF FOAM DOUGHNUT
THAT I WAS POTTY TRAINED ON
30 YEARS EARLIER
WAS STILL BEING USED.
I THINK YOU'LL AGREE
IT'S TIME WE PUT OUR TOILETS
ON A DOUGHNUT-FREE DIET.
LET ME INTRODUCE YOU
TO EZ-PEE-Z.
THIS PRODUCT IS GONNA CHANGE
THE WAY THE WORLD POTTY TRAINS.
NOT ONLY IS IT EASY
FOR THE KIDS,
IT'S ALSO EASY FOR THE PARENTS.
AT FIRST,
IT APPEARS AND OPERATES
AS A NORMAL,
ADULT-SIZED TOILET SEAT,
BUT WITH A SIMPLE FLIP
OF THE LID...
POTTY TRAINING CAN BE
AS EASY AS ONE, TWO...
PEE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, WHO WANTS TO JOIN
THE POTTY?
[ LAUGHS ]
BRIAN,
WHEN YOU FLIP THE LID...
YES, SIR.
...THAT EDGE
COULD PINCH THE SKIN,
WHICH WOULD NOT
HELP WITH --
IT ACTUALLY WON'T PINCH.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT
WITH THE 3-D PRINT.
THERE ARE SOME...
SOME -- SOME HINDRANCES
THAT 3-D PRINTING CANNOT DO,
SUCH AS A LIVING HINGE.
THIS IS CURRENTLY
IN THE PROTOTYPE PHASE.
THE WAY IT'LL BE
ONCE IT GOES TO MANUFACTURING,
IT'LL BE SEAMLESS ON TOP. THERE
WON'T BE ANYTHING YOU CAN SEE.
BUT I ASKED THE QUESTION
BECAUSE THE DOUGHNUT --
WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU LIFT IT?
THE DOUGHNUT
THAT YOU JUST THREW OUT,
IT'S COMFORTABLE
TO SIT ON THAT.
WELL, IT'S PADDED.
IT'S PADDED,
AND THIS IS NOT PADDED.
BUT THE GREAT THING IS, THIS IS
NOT JUST FOR POTTY TRAINING.
THIS INTRODUCES THE CHILD
TO SITTING ON AN ACTUAL TOILET.
CHILDREN NEED A SMALLER SEAT
UP UNTIL THEY'RE 6 YEARS OLD.
I HAVE A 6-YEAR-OLD
RIGHT NOW.
SHE'S TALL AND SKINNY.
SHE DOESN'T USE
THE FOAM DOUGHNUT.
SHE STILL NEEDS
SOMETHING LIKE THIS,
OR SHE IS GONNA FALL
IN THE TOILET.
BRIAN, ACTUALLY,
I HAVE ANOTHER CONCERN WITH IT.
IF I UNDERSTAND
THE IDEA PROPERLY...
MM-HMM.
...FOR ME TO BUY YOUR PRODUCT,
I'D HAVE TO TAKE IT HOME
AND REPLACE
MY EXISTING TOILET-SEAT COVER.
HOW MANY PEOPLE REALLY WANT TO
CHANGE THEIR TOILET SEAT?
IT'S -- IT'S -- IT'S -- IT'S --
IT'S TWO -- IT'S TWO SCREWS.
SO, RIGHT NOW,
LOOKING AT THIS, YOU HAVEN'T --
YOU HAVEN'T SOLD ANY YET.
YOU ARE IN
THE PROTOTYPE STAGE.
CURRENTLY,
IT'S IN THE PROTOTYPE PHASE.
YES, MA'AM.
TELL US
YOUR BACKGROUND.
WELL, I MEAN,
MY BACKGROUND IS PROBABLY
A COMBINATION
OF THE FIVE OF YOU.
I GREW UP
AS A LITTLE MARK CUBAN.
I KNOW YOU WENT DOOR-TO-DOOR,
SELLING GARBAGE BAGS.
[ LAUGHS ]
RIGHT.
MY BROTHER AND I LITERALLY
WENT DOOR-TO-DOOR
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD,
WASHING CARS.
SO, WE WOULD'VE BEEN
BEST FRIENDS IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
OR DIRECT COMPETITION.
I JUST GOT DONE READING
YOUR BOOK, ROBERT,
AND WE HAD THE SAME DADS.
MINE DIDN'T SWEEP A WAREHOUSE,
BUT MINE WENT OUT OF HIS WAY
TO MAKE SURE WE HAD
EVERYTHING THAT WE NEEDED,
KEVIN, WHICH IS
A LOT LIKE YOUR --
YOU KNOW,
YOU BEING A DAD RIGHT NOW.
OKAY, WE GOT YOU
FROM 10 TO 12.
YEAH.
[ CORCORAN LAUGHS ]
13 ON.
[ CHUCKLES ]
SO, SALES AND MARKETING IS
WHAT I DID RIGHT AFTER COLLEGE.
GOT MARRIED, SETTLED DOWN
IN NASHVILLE, TENNESSEE,
AND STARTED FLIPPING HOUSES.
I SAVED UP ENOUGH MONEY
THAT I DID THREE HOMES AT ONCE.
I DID IT IN 2008, WHICH,
AS YOU GUYS KNOW,
WAS PROBABLY
THE WORST TIME TO DO IT.
I LOST ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE PENNY I HAD.
MY WIFE AT THE TIME
DECIDED SHE WANTED
TO GO TO GREENER PASTURES.
I NEVER KNEW HOW MUCH I GAINED
BY LOSING ALMOST EVERYTHING.
BUT I MOVED BACK HOME
TO MY HOMETOWN OF TAMPA,
WHERE I STARTED
MY OWN GYM BUSINESS.
I WENT ALL-IN
ON MY FIRST ONE.
OVER THOSE FOUR YEARS,
I SAVED UP 200 GRAND,
EXPANDED FROM TWO GYMS
TO THREE GYMS,
AND I HAVE THREE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL GYMS IN MY FRANCHISE.
SOMETHING'S
NOT ADDING UP.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU
BEEN WORKING ON THIS?
THE INITIAL CONCEPT
WAS DEVELOPED SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
OKAY, SO,
THE INITIAL CONCEPT.
YOU GET
YOUR GYMS WORKING.
YEAH.
IT'S A
WELL-OILED MACHINE.
KNOWING YOU HAD
ALL THIS TIME,
THE BEST YOU COULD DO
IS A 3-D-PRINTED VERSION OF IT.
IF YOU WERE SO COMMITTED
AND THIS WAS SUCH A GREAT IDEA,
WHY DIDN'T YOU HAVE ALL OF THIS
JUST RUNNING AND HUMMING?
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT I HAD ALL THE I.P. DONE,
GET EVERYTHING TRADEMARKED.
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
I MADE ALL THE RIGHT DECISIONS
SO I DIDN'T LOSE ALL MY MONEY
FLIPPING THREE HOUSES AGAIN.
I'M NOT BUYING IT.
I'M NOT BUYING IT. I'M OUT.
Corcoran:
BRIAN, HERE'S WHAT I DON'T GET.
YES.
I DON'T THINK
IT'S A BIG DEAL
TO REMOVE THAT NICE,
LITTLE CUSHION PAD FOR YOUR KID,
PUT IT UP AND DOWN,
WASH IT IN THE TUB.
IT'S SO EASY.
IT'S A PAIN.
I DON'T KNOW THE LAST TIME
YOU POTTY TRAINED.
A PAIN?
YEAH, NINE YEARS AGO.
YEAH, IT TURNS INTO
A NIGHTMARE.
IT WASN'T A NIGHTMARE.
PLUS, IT'S A VISUAL EYESORE.
I MEAN, JUST -- JUST IMAGINE --
"A VISUAL EYESORE"?
WHEN YOU HAVE COMPANY
COME OVER, YOU KNOW,
YOU DON'T WANT GUESTS
TO SEE THE DOUGHNUT,
OR YOU DON'T WANT
TO SEE THE --
BRIAN, I DON'T BUY INTO IT.
I JUST DON'T GET IT.
I DON'T THINK
IT'S GONNA WORK. I'M OUT.
I APPRECIATE IT.
THANKS FOR LISTENING.
Herjavec: BRIAN.
YES, SIR?
YOU ARE
A GOOD SALESMAN.
THANKS.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A POINT
WHERE IT KIND OF
BECOMES TRANSPARENT.
I MEAN, I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU DID THE RESEARCH,
AND I LOVE HOW
YOU CONNECTED THE STORIES,
BUT JUST AS A GENERAL TIP
IN SALES,
THERE'S A POINT THAT YOU CROSS,
AND, YOU KNOW, FOR ME,
YOU KIND OF JUST CROSSED
THAT POINT -- TOO MUCH SELLING.
I APOLOGIZE
IF I CAME ACROSS THAT WAY.
I'M -- I'M -- I'M --
I'M S--
YEAH, NO, NO, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO APOLOGIZE.
JUST --
JUST MY OBSERVATION.
I'M BEYOND EXCITED
TO BE HERE,
AND IT'S PROBABLY
MY EXCITEMENT COMING THROUGH.
I-I GOT IT, BUT I GOT TO BELIEVE
IN THE PRODUCT.
MM-HMM.
AND IN THIS CASE,
THE IDEA THAT CONSUMERS
ARE GONNA BUY THIS
AND REPLACE
AN EXISTING PRODUCT THAT WORKS,
I-I DON'T BUY THAT.
I'M OUT.
OKAY, I-I APPRECIATE THE TIME
AND YOU LISTENING,
AND THANKS
FOR THE ADVICE.
YOU KNOW, AT FIRST,
IT APPEARED TO ME VERY CLEVER,
LIKE A BETTER MOUSETRAP,
BUT YOU HAVE NO PROOF OF CONCEPT
WHATSOEVER.
BEFORE -- BEFORE YOU --
I DON'T KNOW IF --
I DON'T KNOW
IF WE SHOWED YOU THAT --
MY MOM WOULD BE
VERY UPSET WITH ME
'CAUSE SHE USED TO TELL ME
ALWAYS TO LOWER THE LID
'CAUSE WE HAD A DOG
THAT DRANK OUT OF THE TOILET.
SO, WE DO HAVE A FULL U.S.
UTILITY PATENT ON THE PRODUCT.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, LORD.
SO, I DON'T KNOW IF THAT MAKES
A DIFFERENCE TO EACH OF YOU.
IT'S GREAT
YOU GOT A PATENT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NOT
A LOT OF PEOPLE ACHIEVE,
AND I COMMEND YOU.
DOES THAT CHANGE
YOUR INVESTMENT DECISION?
AND I THINK THAT THIS
HAS POTENTIAL.
BUT I'M OUT.
I APPRECIATE IT.
Cuban:
YOU HAVE ONE SHARK LEFT.
KEVIN?
IN THIS CASE, ALL TOILETS LEAD
BACK TO MR. WONDERFUL.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO, HERE, WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE THIS HAS NO MERIT.
THERE IS NO MARKET FOR THIS,
AND THE GOOD NEWS IS
YOU HAVEN'T
GONE INTO PRODUCTION YET,
SO YOU CAN TAKE THIS
BEHIND THE BARN AND SHOOT IT.
WHY SPEND YOUR TIME
DOING SOMETHING
THAT DOESN'T REALLY SOLVE
ANY PROBLEM?
THERE'S NO PROBLEM.
WELL, 'CAUSE
I'M JUST LIKE YOU GUYS.
I HAVE AN ENTREPRENEURIAL ITCH
IN ME, AND I --
NO, NO,
BUT DOESN'T MEAN YOU --
I HAVE CREATIVITY JUST GOING
THROUGH MY MIND.
COME UP WITH
SOMETHING ELSE!
WHEN YOU WERE
STARTING YOUR COMPANY,
AND YOU ASKED YOUR MOM FOR A
$10,000 LOAN TO START SoftKey --
YES, YES.
YOU ASKED YOUR MOM?!
ABSOLUTELY.
YOU DID?!
AND SHE GAVE IT
TO YOU?!
SO, YOU GOT A $10,000 LOAN
TO START SOFTKEY...
THAT'S RIGHT.
...SO SHE BELIEVED IN YOU.
I'M LOOKING FOR YOU
TO BELIEVE IN ME.
YEAH, BUT, YOU KNOW,
IT WASN'T ABOUT A TOILET SEAT,
AND I THINK...
[ LAUGHTER ]
...HAD SHE LOOKED AT THIS,
SHE WOULD'VE SAID,
"I'M NOT GONNA GIVE YOU ANY
MONEY 'CAUSE IT'S A BAD IDEA."
BRIAN, LET'S CLOSE THE LID
ON THIS.
I'M OUT.
GOOD LUCK, MY FRIEND.
GOOD LUCK, BRIAN.
THIS IS A DOG.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, GUYS.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
THANKS.
Herjavec: IT'S HIS ONLY
PROTOTYPE, KEVIN. BE CAREFUL.
Greiner: SIT ON IT, KEVIN.
[ Laughing ] WHAT ARE YOU
CHECKING OUT, KEVIN?
I CAN FEEL THE HINGE.
BUT --
YOU CAN FEEL THE HINGE?
I CAN DEFINITELY
FEEL THE HINGE.
Kleinschmidt:
I LOOK AT THIS JUST AS A
SPEED BUMP ON THE ROAD OF LIFE.
I-I WILL GO FORWARD,
AND, UM, I WILL PROSPER.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE QUOTES
FROM ROBERT'S BOOKS WAS,
"TOUGH TIMES NEVER LAST.
TOUGH PEOPLE ALWAYS DO,"
AND I'M TOUGH.
♪♪
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A PRODUCT
THE ENTREPRENEURS HOPE IS
THE NEXT BIG FOOD TREND.
HI.
MY NAME IS JOVON ENGLISH.
I'M NAIMAH HARRIS.
I'M MARQUES BROOKS.
WE'RE FROM LOS ANGELES,
CALIFORNIA, AND WE ARE...
Together:
MILK AND BROOKIES.
WE ARE SEEKING $100,000
FOR 20% EQUITY IN OUR COMPANY.
NEW YORK HAS THE CRONUT,
SAN FRANCISCO HAS THE CRUFFIN,
BUT L.A...
BABY, L.A. HAS
THE BROOKIE.
BROOKIES ARE
BROWNIE/COOKIE MASH-UPS.
IT'S WHAT YOU WOULD GET
IF A BROWNIE LIKED A COOKIE,
PUT A RING ON IT,
AND THEN HAD A BABY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HERE AT MILK + BROOKIES,
WE HAVE OVER EIGHT DIFFERENT
SPECIALTY BROOKIES,
INCLUDING THE O.G.,
WHICH IS A FUDGE BROWNIE
AND A CHOCOLATE-CHIP COOKIE.
THE O.G.
THIS IS
WHAT STARTED IT ALL.
OUR BUILD-A-BROOKIE MENU ALLOWS
BROOKIE MONSTERS, OUR FANS,
TO CREATE THEIR OWN
SPECIALTY BROOKIE.
WITH OVER
750 COMBINATIONS,
IT'S ALWAYS A GOOD TIME
FOR MILK + BROOKIES.
ALWAYS.
SO, SHARKS, WE'RE ASKING
THAT YOU TAKE A BITE
AND JOIN
THE BROOKIE REVOLUTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
MARQUES IS GONNA
PASS YOU SAMPLES.
SHORT AND SWEET.
IT'S BROOKIE TIME!
WITH MILK, TOO.
HOW SWEET IS THAT?
-AND MILK?
-AND MILK.
-YES.
-WOW.
-YUMMY.
-ABSOLUTELY.
AND YOU ALL HAVE
YOUR OWN SPECIAL MILK.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
AND, LORI, SOME MILK.
HERE'S THE MILK, BARB.
-NO, NO, THAT'S YOUR MILK.
-NO, LORI, THAT'S YOUR MILK.
-I LOVE PEANUT BUTTER.
-NO, THAT'S YOUR MILK.
GOD!
[ LAUGHTER ]
WOW!
THIS IS SO CONFUSING!
I KNOW!
IT SHOULDN'T BE THIS DIFFICULT!
THAT'S MY OWN MILK?
THAT'S YOURS.
THAT'S WHAT'S UP!
WHAT IS THE CLASSIC ONE --
THE O.G.?
A FUDGE BROWNIE
AND A CHOCOLATE-CHIP COOKIE
WITH THREE TYPES OF CHIPS.
SO, YOU HAVE TO GET EVERYTHING
IN ONE BITE...
WOW.
...BROWNIE AND COOKIE...
-MMM, IT'S GOOD.
-MMM.
...TO GET THE FULL BROOKIE
EXPERIENCE.
THE BLONDIE AND WHAT?
AND A SNICKERDOODLE COOKIE.
SO, WE'VE RUN INTO
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT...
MMM.
...HAD A LITTLE BIT
OF AN AVERSION TO CHOCOLATE,
SO WE CREATED A BLONDIE.
MMM.
SO, IT'S WHITE CHOCOLATE CHIPS,
BUTTERSCOTCH,
AND HEATH
IN A BLOND BROWNIE.
I JUST TASTED IT.
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
THANK YOU.
OH, THIS ONE IS
FANTASTIC.
THESE ARE -- THESE ARE
EXCEPTIONALLY RICH.
THANK YOU.
THEY'RE -- I WOULD SAY
THAT'S 400 TO 500 CALORIES
IN EACH ONE OF THESE.
HOW MANY CALORIES
IN EACH ONE?
DON'T ANSWER THAT.
DON'T TELL US.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO, WE NEED TO KNOW.
WE NEED TO KNOW.
SO, WE ARE SENDING IT OFF
FOR TESTING FOR THE CALORIES.
DO YOU SELL THESE ONLINE?
WE DO SELL THEM ONLINE.
WE HAVE AN INTERNET-BASED
BUSINESS RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S HOW WE OPERATE.
WHAT'S YOUR RELATIONSHIP,
THE THREE OF YOU?
THIS IS MY BEST FRIEND.
AND THIS IS
MY SISTER-FRIEND.
AND WE'RE ROOMMATES.
YEAH.
HOW DID YOU
ALL OF A SUDDEN DECIDE,
"LET'S MAKE SOME CUPCAKES?"
SO, INITIALLY, WE --
I MADE THE BROOKIES.
I TOOK THEM
TO A HOLIDAY PART.
EVERYBODY WANTED ME
TO MAKE SOME MORE.
THEY WANTED TO BUY SOME.
SO, INITIALLY, WE WANTED
TO JUST PAY THE CABLE BILL.
[ LAUGHS ]
"IF WE PAY THIS CABLE BILL,
THIS WILL BE GREAT."
REALLY?
SO, THEN IT'S LIKE, "WELL, LET'S
SEE IF WE CAN PAY THE RENT."
YOU KNOW, AND IT KIND OF GREW...
ORGANICALLY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NECESSITY IS THE MOTHER
OF INVENTION, RIGHT?
-RIGHT?
-YES, YES.
-MY GOSH.
AND WHAT IS
YOUR BACKGROUNDS?
WELL, I COME FROM
THE WORLD OF FINANCE.
I WAS IN BANKING -- PRIVATE
BANKING AND RELATIONSHIP BANKING
FOR OVER 10 YEARS.
THAT'S MY WORLD.
WELL, I GOT OUT OF IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND SO NOW I WORK WITH
A NON-PROFIT ORGANIZATION
THAT SUPPORTS THE HOMELESS,
THE MENTALLY ILL,
PEOPLE RECENTLY RELEASED
FROM INCARCERATION.
YOU'RE NOT FULL-TIME
IN BROOKIES?
NO, I'M NOT FULL-TIME
IN BROOKIES.
WHICH ONE OF YOU
IS FULL-TIME?
NONE OF US.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS DO?
I WORK IN HEALTHCARE.
OKAY, AND, MARQUES?
I WORK IN REAL ESTATE,
BUT MORE SO, SPECIFICALLY,
I WORK IN PROPERTY MANAGEMENT.
SO, YOU GUYS ARE DOING THIS
WHENEVER YOU HAVE TIME.
WE -- WE MAKE TIME TO DO IT.
NO, WE DON'T SLEEP.
SO, LITERALLY,
WE'RE OPERATING ON NAPS.
YOU GUYS PROBABLY KNOW
WICKED GOOD CUPCAKES.
THAT'S ONE OF MY DEALS.
AND AS WE GREW, THEY STARTED
WORKING 18 HOURS A DAY.
I MEAN,
IT IS A FULL-TIME GIG.
AND THERE WERE TWO PARTNERS,
BY THE WAY.
SO, THE WAY IT WORKS, AFTER
WORK, WE COLLECT THE ORDERS.
EVERY ORDER MUST BE RECEIVED
BY 7:00 PACIFIC STANDARD TIME,
AND WE'RE ABLE
TO EITHER SHIP THEM
OR HAVE THEM DELIVERED
THE FOLLOWING DAY.
AND YOU SHIP THEM FRESH?
YES, WE BAKE EVERYTHING
TO ORDER.
Greiner:
YOU GO INTO THE KITCHEN,
AND YOU ACTUALLY STIR THE FOOD
AND MAKE IT YOURSELF?
-MM-HMM.
-YES.
Herjavec: JOVON --
AND YET
YOU'RE CUSTOMIZING
EACH ORDER --
750 DIFFERENT CONFIGURATIONS?
YOU KNOW
YOU CAN'T SCALE THAT.
WELL, HOW MUCH
HAVE YOU SOLD SO FAR?
SO, RIGHT NOW
IN TERMS OF SALES,
WE'VE SOLD
$14,000 WORTH OF BROOKIES.
IN THE CUPCAKE,
CONFECTIONERY GIFTING BUSINESS,
WHICH I THINK
IS WHAT BROOKIES IS...
MM-HMM.
...THE ONLY WAY TO SURVIVE SCALE
AND GROWING
IS TO STANDARDIZE
AROUND FOUR PRODUCTS.
RIGHT. OKAY.
THAT'S IT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO KIND OF MANAGE
INVENTORY EXPECTATION.
YOU'RE SHIPPING FRESH,
YOU CAN'T HAVE 750 OPTIONS.
THAT'S THE DEFINITION OF HELL
IN CUPCAKE LAND.
RIGHT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU CAN'T --
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
AND WHAT DO YOU
SELL SIX CUPCAKES FOR --
PARDON ME --
BROOKIES FOR?
WITHOUT NUTS,
THEY'RE SOLD FOR $14.
WITH NUTS,
THEY'RE SOLD FOR $17.
AND DO YOU KNOW
WHAT IT COSTS YOU TO MAKE?
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL BROOKIE
WITHOUT NUTS,
IT COSTS US 75 TO MAKE.
WITH NUTS,
IT COSTS US 91 CENTS.
ARE YOU SURE?
WAIT, IS THAT $14
FOR SIX OF THEM,
OR $14 FOR
THE ONE PER CAKE?
-$14 FOR SIX.
-FOR SIX.
OOH, YOU'RE NOT CHARGING
NEAR ENOUGH.
IF YOU LOOK
AT THE CUPCAKE BUSINESS,
YOU HAVE TO SELL SIX
AT A TIME.
OKAY.
RIGHT?
AND YOU'VE GOT
TO GET $20 FOR IT.
FOR THESE, MORE THAN THAT
BECAUSE WHAT YOU GIVE,
OFFER NOW
IS A CUSTOMIZED SERVICE.
RIGHT.
PRODUCT IS AMAZING.
I MEAN,
YOU'VE GOT PROBABLY
THE BEST PRODUCT TASTER
AND TESTER IN THE WORLD THERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YEAH, MARQUES.
GO, MARQUES! GO, MARQUES!
GO, MARQUES!
HE'S THE LEADER
OF OUR DANCE TEAM.
RIGHT, HE IS.
BROOKIES ARE MADE
WITH LOVE.
IT SHOULD BE
$9.95 EACH.
NO, IT SHOULD BE $30 FOR SIX.
THAT'S THE SWEET SPOT.
OR $30 -- $30 FOR SIX.
YOUR CHOICE, RIGHT?
OKAY.
Harris: OKAY.
EVEN THOUGH YOUR SALES
IN TERMS OF NUMBER OF UNITS
MIGHT GO DOWN SOME,
YOUR PROFITS ARE GOING TO GO UP.
RIGHT.
MM.
BECAUSE YOUR BIGGEST LIMIT
IS YOUR TIME.
RIGHT.
MM-HMM.
THAT'S YOUR
MOST VALUABLE ASSET.
SO, YOU DON'T NEED
THE MOST NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS
IN THE WORLD.
YOU NEED TO MAXIMIZE
YOUR RETURN ON YOUR TIME.
BUT UNTIL THEN,
YOU'RE A BAKE SALE,
YOU'RE NOT A BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
SO, EVERYBODY'S REINVENTING
YOUR BUSINESS PLAN FOR YOU,
BUT LET'S CALL IT
WHAT IT IS.
YOU FORMED
A BAKING SOCIAL CLUB,
AND YOU CAME HERE
TO THE "SHARK TANK."
THERE IS NO C.E.O.
THERE'S NO EMPLOYEES.
THERE'S JUST YOU GUYS
BAKING CUPCAKES.
IT'S US.
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING.
YOU'RE A HOBBY,
YOU'RE NOT A BUSINESS.
I'M IN THIS SPACE.
UM, I KNOW WHAT IT TAKES
TO SUCCEED IN IT.
YOU DON'T HAVE IT YET.
I'M OUT.
DID I HEAR YOU SAY
THERE'S A DANCE TEAM?
NOT TODAY.
WHILE WE'RE
COOKING BROOKIES,
WE ARE DANCING
WITH THE MUSIC,
AND HE'S
THE LEADER OF OUR --
PLAYING BEYONCé.
PSEUDO-BEYONCé.
Herjavec:
OH, THERE WE GO!
[ LAUGHTER ]
HEY, THAT'S
HOW WE DO IT, MAN.
MARQUES,
LOVED THE PRODUCT.
THANK YOU.
EVERYBODY HERE LOVED
THE TASTE OF THE PRODUCT.
THANK YOU.
WHEN PRODUCTS SHOW UP
ON "SHARK TANK,"
ESPECIALLY FOOD PRODUCTS
THAT WE ALL LOVE...
THINGS BLOW UP.
I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA
MAKE A LOT OF MONEY.
THAT WOULD BE AWESOME.
WE'RE READY.
BUT YOU'RE A LITTLE EARLY.
I'M GONNA
SAY NO TO THE BROOKIE,
BUT CALL ME
FOR THE DANCE TEAM.
OKAY.
ABSOLUTELY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I LOVE
ABOUT THE THREE OF YOU?
WHAT IS THAT?
YOUR PERSONALITY.
-OH, THANK YOU.
-THANK YOU.
USUALLY, YOU GET ONE GOOD
PERSONALITY AND TWO CLUNKERS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHO'S THE CLUNKER,
BARBARA?!
IT'S THE TRUTH!
BUT YOU HAVE NO CLUNKERS HERE.
NO CLUNKERS?!
YOU'RE TRIPPING OVER EACH OTHER
WITH PERSONALITY,
AND SO IT'S CONTAGIOUS.
YOU JUST WANT TO JOIN
THAT PARTY,
BUT YOU'RE EXACTLY LIKE
DAISY CAKES,
WHO MADE
ALL THE WRONG MISTAKES
WHEN SHE AIRED
ON "SHARK TANK" NIGHT.
HER WEBSITE CRASHED.
IT WAS CRAZY.
SHE LOST OVER...
$350,000 IN SALES
IN ONE NIGHT.
WOW.
Harris: WOW.
IT WAS A HEARTBREAKER.
SHE WAS BAKING 100 --
I THINK IT WAS $112,000
WORTH OF CAKES WHEN SHE APPEARED
ON "SHARK TANK."
YOU'VE GOT...$14,000.
YOU'RE TOO EARLY.
I'M OUT.
-OKAY.
I SEE IT AS, LIKE, YOU'RE TRYING
TO SELL US A FOREST
WHILE RIGHT NOW,
YOU'RE A LITTLE ACORN.
THE THING IS
YOU GUYS ARE VERY EARLY.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL YOUR ADVICE.
THANKS, GUYS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
-CONGRATS, GUYS.
-THANK YOU.
-MARQUES?
-COME ON.
-ENJOY THE PROCESS.
-YEAH, DO IT.
Herjavec: COME ON.
[ LAUGHTER ]
COME ON.
TELL ME 'BOUT THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
-SEE YOU, GUYS.
-THANK YOU. TAKE CARE.
-THANK YOU! BYE!
-BYE.
-THANK YOU.
Greiner: OKAY.
THEY WERE SO MUCH FUN.
OH, MY GOSH.
WE DID IT.
IT WASN'T THAT BAD.
WE'RE OKAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THEY SAW IT.
WE MADE IT.
THEY LOVED IT.
WE SURVIVED.
THIS IS
A REALLY GOOD IDEA.
ARE YOU DOING BEYONCé?
[ LAUGHS ]
♪♪
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK IS
A MORE CIVILIZED WAY
TO HANDLE YOUR DAILY BUSINESS.
HI, SHARKS,
MY NAME'S SEAN RILEY,
AND I'M HERE
WITH MY GOOD FRIENDS,
RYAN MEEGAN AND JEFF KLIMKOWSKI,
AND WE'RE THE GUYS
OF DUDE PRODUCTS,
HAILING FROM CHICAGO,
ILLINOIS.
BUT YOU CAN JUST CALL US
"THE DUDES."
DUDE.
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY,
SEEKING $300,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10%
OF OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, ARE YOU STILL WIPING
THE OLD-FASHION WAY
WITH JUST TOILET PAPER?
IF SO...YOU'RE A CHUMP, AND YOUR
ASS PROBABLY HATES YOU FOR IT.
[ CORCORAN CHUCKLES ]
BUT, HEY, WHAT'S A DUDE TO DO?
YOU COULD TRY
SOME BABY WIPES.
BUT WE'RE NOT BABIES,
WE'RE DUDES!
SO WE CREATED
THE AWARD-WINNING DUDE WIPES.
THEY'RE THE VERY FIRST WIPES
FOR, WELL, DUDES.
THEY'RE FLUSHABLE,
BIODEGRADABLE,
HAVE SOOTHING ALOE, AND THE
ANSWER TO EVERY DUDE'S PRAYERS.
NOW, DUDES
FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE
CAN USE DUDE WIPES
FROM BLUE-COLLAR DUDES
TO COLLEGE BROS
TO BUSINESS GUYS,
EVEN MOMS WITH LITTLE,
SMELLY DUDES.
I EVEN CAUGHT MY WIFE
STEALING DUDE WIPES.
AND DUDE WIPES AREN'T
JUST FOR TAKING CARE OF BUSINESS
ON THE THRONE.
THEY'RE ALSO SAFE
FOR YOUR FACE, PITS, HANDS,
AND THEY COMBAT STINK
FOR ALL DUDE REGIONS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, SHARKS, WHICH ONE OF YOU
ARE READY TO JOIN IN THE CRUSADE
OF SAVING THE WORLD...
Together:
ONE DUDE AT A TIME.
[ CHUCKLES ] ROBERT,
DON'T GO UP AND TRY THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO, PLEASE DO, ROBERT.
LET'S SEE.
CAN WE SEE THEM?
-WOULD YOU GUYS LIKE TO CHECK
SOME OUT?
-YEAH.
-YEAH, LET'S SHOW THEM.
WE WILL HOOK YOU UP
WITH THE DUDE WIPES.
DUDE!
HERE YOU GO, ROBERT.
YOU CAN TAKE ONE OF
OUR SOFT PACKS.
DOES IT HAVE, LIKE,
DUDE COLOGNE SCENT?
NO, IT'S ACTUALLY FRAGRANCE-FREE
AND FRESH SCENTS.
OUR GOAL --
SO, THE ONE
MR. WONDERFUL'S HOLDING IS
A NATURAL
HEALTH-AND-BEAUTY PRODUCT.
THAT FITS ME.
I'M NATURAL AND BEAUTIFUL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, HERE'S A QUESTION
FOR YOU DUDES.
USUALLY,
WHEN I GO ANYWHERE,
THERE'S ALREADY TOILET PAPER
THERE FOR ME.
NOW I HAVE TO CARRY
THE DUDE WIPE WITH ME.
RIGHT.
WELL, DON'T YOU GET
THE DIFFERENCE?
NO. WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE?
-THAT'S THE COMPLEMENT
TO TOILET PAPER.
-YEAH.
-YOU FINISH IT OFF
WITH THE DUDE WIPE.
-OH, THIS IS THE FINISHING?
-OH.
-YEAH, IT'S THE --
-YEAH.
-OH, THIS IS THE FINISHER?
-RIGHT THERE.
WE CALL IT
THE SECOND-TO-LAST WIPE.
[ LAUGHS ]
SEE, WE WERE USING BABY WIPES
IN OUR APARTMENT IN CHICAGO.
THAT'S HOW WE GOT STARTED.
NO, DUDE!
-I DON'T BUY IT.
-100%.
-I KNOW --
I DON'T BUY IT.
NO, LISTEN,
WAIT, WAIT.
THREE GUYS LIVING TOGETHER
IN CHICAGO,
AND YOU'RE USING
BABY WIPES?
WELL, YEAH, WE WERE.
BUT I'M GONNA
TELL YOU SOMETHING.
THERE'S A LITTLE PROBLEM
WITH THIS.
THE MINUTE I TOOK IT
OUT OF THE PACKAGE,
MY FINGER WENT
RIGHT THROUGH THAT.
IT'S TOO FRAGILE, AND...
IT'S TRAGIC, ACTUALLY.
...AND BY THE WAY, THIS IS
TOO SMALL FOR MY HUSBAND.
HE'S 6'1".
I MEAN, I FEEL LIKE
HE NEEDS SOMETHING
TWICE AS BIG AS THIS.
GOT A BIG BUTT?
[ LAUGHS ]
WE'RE HAVING A LOT OF FUN
WITH IT.
LET'S GET SERIOUS
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE YOU COULD
PROVE US ALL WRONG
AND OUR SKEPTICISM BY TELLING US
YOU HAVE LOTS OF SALES
BECAUSE YOU PUT A VALUATION
ON THIS BUSINESS OF $3 MILLION.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE SALES,
I'M GONNA WIPE
YOUR YOU-KNOW-WHAT WITH THIS.
SO, YEAR TO DATE,
WE HAVE $300,000,
BUT WE'RE PROJECTING
$1.5 MILLION FOR THIS YEAR.
WHY?
'CAUSE WE JUST LANDED
A $2- TO $3-MILLION CONTRACT
TO GO NATIONWIDE
WITH KROGER.
WOW!
KROGER'S PUTTING YOU IN?
DUDE WIPES ARE
GOING INTO KROGER?
WE'VE ALREADY TESTED
WITH THEM,
AND THIS IS A COMPLETE
NATIONAL ROLLOUT...
AH.
...IN THE
TOILET-PAPER AISLE,
WHICH IS
THE MOST CONSUMABLE AISLE.
SO, BASICALLY,
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE ROLLING OUT
IN 1,500 TO 2,200 STORES.
IT'S ABOUT $168,000
A MONTH.
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
$6.49 KROGER WILL BE SELLING
THAT GUY FOR.
WE MAKE ABOUT 40% MARGIN
IN STORES AND 60% MARGIN ONLINE.
SO, YOURS SELLS FOR $6.49.
WHAT DOES THE BABY WIPE --
SAME PACKAGE -- SELL FOR?
I JUST WANT TO DO
A COMPARISON.
PROBABLY HALF THE PRICE
FOR THE SAME SIZE.
SO, WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH MY $300,000
IF I GIVE IT TO YOU?
WELL, WE'RE GONNA USE THAT
TO GO GET NEW BIG-BOX RETAILERS.
WE HAVE
THE WORKING CAPITAL.
THE MONEY TO DO KROGER.
Herjavec: SO, JEFF, YOU'VE DONE
$300,000 IN SALES.
WHAT'S YOUR MARKETING SPEND?
WE SPEND 10% TO 15%
FOR EVERY DOLLAR WE SPEND,
SO WE REINVEST IN OUR --
SO YOU'RE NOT MAKING ANY MONEY
YET, RIGHT?
WELL, NO, WE ARE 'CAUSE WE HAVE
40% GROSS MARGINS.
BUT ARE YOU
PAYING YOURSELVES ANYTHING?
UH, WE'RE PAYING SEAN.
I'M THE FULL-TIME SALARY TO GET
THE COMPANY GOING.
AND WHAT ARE
THE OTHER DUDES DOING?
SO, I'M AN
INVESTMENT BANKER, AND...
I WORK FOR MY DAD'S
MANUFACTURING COMPANY.
WHAT DO YOU MANUFACTURE?
ACTUALLY,
BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
LUXURY MOBILE RESTROOM TRAILERS
AND SHOWERS.
IT'S IN YOUR BLOOD!
[ CHUCKLES ]
THAT'S RIGHT.
Cuban: GUYS, LOOK,
I LIKE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I THINK YOU'LL BE SUCCESSFUL.
BUT I'VE GOT TWO PROBLEMS.
I JUST DON'T SEE ME AS
A WIPES KIND OF GUY. I'M SORRY.
SECOND, I THINK
YOU'RE UNDERESTIMATING
THE AMOUNT OF MARKETING DOLLARS
IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TO REALLY OPEN UP
A NEW CATEGORY.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A RIDE
THAT I CAN TAKE,
SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
APPRECIATE YOUR POINTS.
THANK YOU.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I THINK.
I HAVEN'T HAD MY HUSBAND STEP
FOOT IN A TOILET-PAPER AISLE
SINCE I MARRIED HIM.
MEN DON'T SHOP FOR TOILET PAPER
FOR THE MOST PART.
THEIR WIVES DO, SO I THINK
YOU HAVE TO SELL IT TO THE WIFE.
I'M NOT SURE
THEY'RE GONNA BUY IN,
ESPECIALLY
WITH THE ADVANCE KNOWLEDGE
THAT THE PRICE
ON THESE DUDE WIPES
ARE EXACTLY DOUBLE WHAT
THEY PAID FOR THE BABY WIPES.
ALSO, I PUNCHED
MY FINGER THROUGH IT
WITHOUT EVEN TRYING...
THAT SCARES ME.
...AND I CAN'T SHAKE THAT
OUT OF MY HEAD.
SO I WISH YOU LUCK,
BUT THEY'RE NOT FOR ME. I'M OUT.
Greiner:
I LOVE YOU, DUDES.
I LIKE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
BUT YOU WANT $300,000
FOR 10%. WHY?
WHERE DOES THAT COME FROM?
I KNOW YOU'RE GETTING INTO
KROGER, BUT...
YEAH. I MEAN, BASICALLY,
TWO TO THREE TIMES YOUR REVENUE,
AND I UNDERSTAND
WE'RE VERY EARLY...
REVENUE?
...AND ALL THAT
KIND OF STUFF.
'CAUSE YOU -- GUYS -- YOU KNOW
THIS. YOU'RE THE BANKER GUY.
YOU'RE WORTH
ABOUT A MILLION BUCKS TODAY.
YOU SAID $300,000 PRE-TAX,
ABOUT $230,000 AFTER TAX.
NO ONE'S GONNA PAY YOU
MORE THAN FIVE TIMES FOR THAT.
NO ONE'S GONNA VALUE YOU
AT EVEN A MULTIPLE,
AN EARNINGS MULTIPLE, BUT YOU
THREE DUDES ARE GONNA RUN FAST.
I WANT TO COME ALONG AND RUN,
TOO, BUT THE VALUE I SEE IS...
$300,000 FOR 25%.
BECAUSE TO GET TO THE
$3 MILLION VALUE, I SEE RISK.
I WASN'T GONNA GIVE YOU
ANY MORE THAN THAT EITHER.
THAT'S MY OFFER.
I'D GIVE YOU $300,000 FOR 25%.
THAT'S THE RIGHT PRICE
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES AHEAD.
IT'S A FAIR PRICE,
ACTUALLY.
DUDE, HE'S TRYING
TO WIPE YOU OUT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO, I DON'T THINK.
UNLESS LORI CAN TAKE --
I THINK IT'S A --
LET ME SHARE WITH YOU
MY THOUGHTS.
FROM THE FEMALE POINT OF VIEW,
I THINK THE FACT
THAT YOU GUYS ARE CLEANER DUDES
IS QUITE APPEALING.
I THINK
YOUR PACKAGING IS GREAT.
IT'S VERY CLEAR --
DUDE WIPES.
CAN'T BE SIMPLER THAN THAT,
AND IN THE RIGHT SECTION,
YOU KNOW JUST WHAT IT'S FOR.
SOUNDS LIKE
A BIG OFFER'S COMING.
BUT, UM, I FEEL
I DON'T AGREE WITH
THE $3-MILLION VALUATION.
FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT, BUT...
-WHAT?!
-...I LIKE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
YEAH, BUT, LORI,
WHY ARE YOU OUT?
O'Leary: WHY?!
I'M LEAVING IT
TO MY DUDES NEXT TO ME.
SO, GUYS,
YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
♪♪
Narrator: THE ENTREPRENEURS HAVE
TWO OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FROM ROBERT AND KEVIN,
BOTH AT $300,000 FOR 25%
OF DUDE WIPES --
WET WIPES FOR MEN.
Greiner:
SO, GUYS, YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
WE'D LIKE TO COUNTER --
$300,000 FOR 20% OF THE COMPANY
BUT SPLITTING, SO $150,000
FOR 10% OF THE COMPANY BY KEVIN,
$150,000 FOR 10%
OF THE COMPANY BY ROBERT.
NOT CHANGING THE VALUE.
CAN'T DO IT.
YOU KNOW,
IF YOU GET TWO SHARKS,
THAT'S EVEN MORE VALUABLE,
AND --
YEAH, I WAS ACTUALLY THINKING,
IF YOU WANT TWO OF US,
WE SHOULD GO TO 30%.
I'LL -- I'LL WORK WITH --
YEAH, YOU KNOW,
I HAVE THE FEELING, TOO.
W-WE'LL DO A DEAL
AT 25%.
TWO SHARKS ARE WORTH --
TWO SHARKS AT 25%.
NO, BUT I --
HE -- HE SPARKED --
THEY JUST SAID
TWO SHARKS AT 25%.
YEAH, BUT THEY'RE CHANGING
THEIR MINDS.
DO YOU CHANGE YOUR MIND?
I APPRECIATE ROBERT'S GREED,
AND I'M ENDORSING IT NOW.
[ LAUGHS ]
GUYS, 30% -- WE'RE
GONNA MAKE THIS WORK FOR YOU.
IT'S VERY, VERY HARD TO GET
TWO GUYS TO PLAY BALL LIKE THIS.
WELL, DUDES?
WE'LL TAKE THE INITIAL OFFER
FOR 25% THIS TIME.
LET'S DO THE CLASSIC
NEGOTIATING.
LET'S SPLIT
THE MIDDLE -- 27.5%
TWO SHARKS, 27.5%.
TELL THEM TO SHOVE IT
UP THEIR BUTTS.
Riley: 25%. COME ON, GUYS.
LET ME MAKE THIS WORK.
25%. 25%, THEN
WE GOT A DEAL.
WE'RE ALREADY --
WE STARTED AT 10%, SO...
GUYS WE HAD --
KEVIN, ROBERT?
I THINK THE EXTRA 2.5% IS WORTH
HAVING TWO GUYS.
THAT TELLS YOU
THEY'RE NOT THAT INTO IT
IN THE FIRST PLACE,
GUYS.
Corcoran: YEAH.
SERIOUSLY.
MARK, YOU MAKE
COMMENTS LIKE THAT --
YOU'RE NOT EVEN
IN THE DEAL.
IT'S TRUE!
IT'S TRUE.
IT'S OUR MONEY.
WE CAN DO WHAT WE WANT.
WHAT DID HE SAY?
WELL, MARK, IT GOES
THE OTHER WAY, TOO.
SAVE YOUR SOUL AND GET
OUT OF HERE WITHOUT THESE GUYS.
THEY SWITCHED
THE DEAL ON YOU.
H-HERE'S THE THING --
HERE'S THE THING, YOU GUYS.
IT SHOULD BE PAINFUL
IF IT'S A GREAT DEAL,
AND IT'S HURTING YOU,
IT'S A GOOD DEAL.
AND WHY WOULD THE 2.5%
MEAN ANYTHING TO THESE GUYS?
THEY'RE JUST
BEING GREEDY.
Herjavec: YOU GOT TO LOOK AT IT
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
I'M LOWERING
MY OWN EQUITY.
I'M TAKING LESS
TO GET KEVIN INVOLVED.
I SEE VALUE
OF HAVING MULTIPLE GUYS.
IT'S 27.5%. EVERYBODY HAS
AN OPINION ONCE THEY'RE OUT.
WE'RE FIGHTING OVER 2.5%.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
HOW LONG DO YOU WANT TO WAIT?
THINK OF THE SHARKS. YOU
GOT A BULLY AND A PRETTY BOY.
SEE, ISN'T IT FUNNY
HOW THERE'S SO MUCH TALK
FROM PEOPLE
WHEN THEY GO OUT?
HEY, BARBARA,
YOU'RE JUST MAKING NOISE.
Greiner: ALL RIGHT, WHAT --
WHAT DO YOU GUYS WANT TO DO?
YOU HAVE ONE DECISION TO MAKE,
AND THEN ONCE YOU'VE MADE IT,
IT'S OVER.
I'LL DO IT.
COME ON.
300K, 25%.
YEAH.
-WHOA!
-LET'S GO.
-YES!
-COME HERE.
YES!
AWESOME!
GOOD JOB.
THANKS, MARK.
THANKS, GUYS.
WE'LL CRUSH IT.
-THANK YOU.
-AWESOME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
YES, SIR!
Herjavec: OH, MAN.
YEAH, WHAT STYLE!
I-I ORIGINALLY WAS HESITANT
BECAUSE I'M NOT --
I'M NOT GONNA BE
A WIPES GUY.
THAT'S NOT MY STYLE.
YOU MIGHT.
BUT THESE GUYS WERE SMART,
THEY WERE AGGRESSIVE,
THEY KNEW
WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
Klimkowski: THIS COULDN'T HAVE
WORKED OUT BETTER.
Meegan: MARK CAME IN
OUT OF NOWHERE, SWOOPED IT UP,
AND THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
MARK'S THE DUDE.
YEP.